hello freak [ __ ] when all that [ __ ]
went down with Chris Kyle and the fan
when he said that he punched you in a
bar yeah you sued the family like no I
didn't well I didn't choose fancied him
rather excuse me i shooed him and he
died and then the chute automatically
goes to his estate that's the way the
legal works she was never in any
jeopardy because in any writers contract
you have insurance from the publisher so
it's me a poor trade and I became the
villain going after the widow and the
kids exactly that's the biggest lie it
was a big insurance company that's
covering the whole thing they're not out
of pammi and they won't be out of pan
but you had to explain that I'm sure
over and over no I couldn't explain it
that's the tie the trial got overturned
because the insurance came out so it's
okay to lie in court but if the truth
comes out you can get a new trial the
insurance came out what does that mean
in court you're not allowed to say that
insurance is paying for everything even
though it's the truth you're not allowed
to say that in court so what happens
when you say it in court well it came
out and the judge allowed it to a
limited degree and then the appeals
court ruled that the judge shouldn't
have did that because having the judge
say that it sways people wonderful
gentle against the insurance company
yeah because insurance company even even
though the other side is doing what's
called poor mouthing they're getting up
and saying it's taxing them financially
and lying the truth is insurance is
paying for all of it don't get up and
lie about it so the other side was
saying this is going to devastate our
family a reality though yeah trying to
influence these and and in this case let
me state this how overwhelming must the
evidence of been for the jury to go
against the grieving widow of the dead
war veteran yeah it must be pretty
overwhelming the evidence was
overwhelming the the jury went from they
came for me they said he was lied this
didn't happen and we rewarding why do
you think he did that did you know him
no you didn't
no he mean I didn't know even how he was
how the thing happened we were there on
the same night we were at McPeake cuz I
was there for a graduation of class 258
I'm class 58 it's traditionally every
hundred classes if you can you come back
to the graduation so class 258 was
graduating the next day on Friday I came
out along with my teammates from class
58 to attend that graduation the next
day so why would I say bad things about
the seals if I'm there that's what he
said he punched me for well tell me cuz
I people don't know what we're talking
about it's probably probably a lot of
people listen to this have no idea what
we're talking about so let me just fill
him in real quick right
the the book American sniper the movie
with Bradley Cooper was just giant hit
movie very patriotic movie about a guy
was one of the most successful snipers
in US history right a very successful
warrior Navy SEAL war hero everybody
loved him then he goes on the Opie and
Anthony show and he says that he punched
you out well there's a chapter in his
book yes where he writes that he called
me scruff face yeah and he said that I
said seals deserve to die that in other
words she accused me of treason yes and
I was out there for a seal graduation if
I felt that way about my old unit why
would I be attending so he wrote in the
book he gave you a nickname in the book
scruff face whoever I mean he might not
have even when he wrote it in the book
he might not have even thought that he's
gonna give that to you I mean who knows
what was going on my thought was at the
time I was trying to wrap my head around
why anybody would do this and I was
thinking well maybe he's just trying to
generate as much controversy as possible
to generate as much income as possible
from his book and it just got out of
hand
I don't I mean I was trying to put it
together because there was a couple
other fabrications right there was a
shooting at a gas station that never
took place yeah and and he said that he
during Katrina he was on the dome and
shot people who were looting yeah that
was the I mean because that's murder
yeah and he also lied about his medals
the Navy had to come out and correct he
said he had two silver stars and five
Bronze Stars he had one Silver Star and
three bronze stars so he lied about
three medals well that's it said one in
three is impressive enough exactly yeah
exactly and then they try to give him an
excuse saying well he was confused no
you're not when you get a medal like
that
it's like graduating from college they
give you a certificate that puts on your
wall if you win the bronze star or the
silver star but as of as in seal
yourself and if me under the bus what
does that feel like to you because
reason but this is obviously this is
something that's very near and dear to
your heart who hugely he has made it to
where I can't go to a reunion anymore
there were a hundred and seventy seals
that wanted me kicked out of the UDT
SEAL Association over his lie and the
lies of his buddies who came up and
tried to testify for him so what it got
embarrassing his in the trial said that
it actually happened no they couldn't
say it but they tried to say everything
else to make it seem like it did well
how the hell they do that well because
they dance around the questions and the
lawyer ring and well you have to piece
together
there wasn't one witness that saw me get
hit and there wasn't one witness that
heard me say anything's he attributed to
me and weren't you visible the next day
yeah we hit first no pie photographs
that night then posing for pictures with
me if I had said all this stuff why
would they have take pictures with me
what does that feel like when someone
just [ __ ] lies horrible and and when
lies about a terrible terrible and
what's worse about it is the media jumps
on it and convicts me of it because why
they broke the story when I went off the
grid Mexico where I couldn't even come
back so they broke the story do you
think they knew then you started believe
it but weren't what didn't it happen on
the Opie and Anthony show yeah but I
don't think that was planned because I
know those guys they are but they're but
was the whole while they also did it he
did it that day
Riley later that afternoon so he once he
named you he just started naming you
every oh yeah then it went viral it went
viral
and everyone convicted me because they
said well this Iraq war veteran would
lie
really I just watched oh well let me
tell you all that it's destroyed my life
I can't get hired for a job during my
trial after it was over guess what
happened 34 major media conglomerates
entered the the trial with that amaz
amma see they call it or whatever of
influencing the Court of Appeals to
overturn my verdict and they did it
34 media conglomerates the New York
Times The Washington Post all of these
media conglomerates appeal to the Court
of Appeals to overturn my verdict but
why because I won on think something
called unjust enrichment they want the
ability to be able to defame you and
profit from it in other words I'll put
it what they had what these judges
accommodated them with there's going to
be another trial they've ordered a new
trial so I got to go through it again
but I'm glad because when it comes out
to juries and to judges find Kyle guilty
who's not going to believe it then and
but the point is they they've ordered a
new trial they've they do out the whole
verdict of the jury the federal judge
who wrote substantial evidence
supporting the jury's verdict they did
all that and they violated their own
rules a 76 year rule here's what it
states if because it happened during
summation where the judge allowed it in
the my attorney it ended up four
questions in an 11 day trial and a half
a page of a 20-page summary and it was
overturned on that and they overturned
it because they felt that was undue
influence on the jury that they found
out that insurance was paying for
everything so is that one factor well
and here's the deal if the rule state
that if in final
argument they say something you must
object
you must object so the trial lawyer has
a chance to rule during final argument
and the jury has a chance to hear the
ruling they never objected so they must
object to undue influence because of the
fact that it was no either way they
never wait they never objected the jury
was dismissed at 11:58 at 12:02 they
then objected the judge overruled them
and we were done with it well these two
judges Reilly and Shepard have now
overturned the case on something that
was never objected to in trial they
objected to it so they overturned the
jury and the federal judge then they
also overturned my unjust enrichment
claim because the media didn't want it
what they've allowed now is the media
can defame you and profit from it and
you can't get any of their profits in no
matter how they harm you well that's the
equivalent of if you went out and robbed
the bank and they caught you and they
sentence you to two years in prison for
the bank robbery but when you get out
you get to keep all the money you took
so that's in this particular one yeah
talk about this particular which will
now be the standard as they've ruled
that way they now make it to where you
can profit from wrongdoing because of
this case yep you see that this is such
a touchy case because it's so indicative
of the complications of people because
people are not simple it's really very
touchy he lied he did lie but he has
room to be with his lie that but that's
not what I'm saying what's complicated
is he's also the subject of this
gigantic movie and this symbol of
patriotism where so many people will say
Chris Kyle rest in peace so many people
would have I saw a cloud that was
someone took a photo in the cloud that's
on a cloud that's a Chris Chris Kyle
it'll look like a sniper in the cloud
unless it's Chris Kyle guiding the
guarding the skies like it became a meme
I mean he became this
thing where it wasn't he was a
representative of the the brave military
like the the portrayal but honestly the
betrayal that Bradley Cooper played in
that movie that movie was so simplistic
and so it was it was like a brat of a
Joseph koke our hero's journey had I not
gone to court that would have been in
the movie really I had to stop it they
were gonna have him punch you in the
movie well for the book holy [ __ ] and I
had to stop it
because you know when we were when we
were in trial you know what they tried
to do to diminish my role because when
they knew they were going to lose their
lawyer got me on the stand and he said
mr. Ventura he said would it surprise
you to know that the first draft of the
movie doesn't have you in it trying to
prove how insignificant my would say the
first draft of the movie I mean [ __ ]
well the first draft is that yeah but so
what if the second draft has you in it
though I set here's what my response I
said no that wouldn't surprise me at all
because I said we've sent two letters to
Warner Brothers warning them that if I'm
indeed in in this movie they will be
next to be sued so we put Warner
Brothers on notice that if this chapters
included in your movie you will get sued
next and you know people out here they
don't want to step into a lawsuit that's
the only thing that kept me from being
punched out in that movie and portrayed
me as a villain in that frickin movie I
just I'm just a villain way more than a
villain yeah right I mean that is insane
it is insane because what's what's crazy
to me and what's complicated about this
is that there are thousands and
thousands of brave men and women who
risked their lives sacrifice their lives
and this guy becomes this this way your
head when where is where he rises above
including me including you yes very
important but he rises above all this
and becomes this icon for yes this
iconic figure that you can't tarnish and
then the truth is irrelevant and they're
willing
sacrifice people like you and the truth
just for this overall image of
patriotism yep
it's crazy what a crazy place that must
have been for you still is in fact do
you know that this person that I told
you about with the seizures the seizure
disorder started right after this I'm
sure that a seizure sign doctor Osman
doctors have said seizures can be caused
by stress so I hold Chris Kyle directly
responsible for the seizure disorder
also that I had to face that marijuana
cured
did you ever communicate with him face
to face only once at the first when we
first and June I didn't even know who he
was and then at in June of 2012 after
the book came out in January we had a
settlement conference where he kept
saying that if he met me in person we
could work it out so at this conference
we agreed I would meet him in a room the
judge in the corner and just ski and I
like you and I are here we sat down in
the room and I looked him right in the
face and I said why did you do this you
never punched me he looked me back and
said yes I did I turned to the judge I
said there's no need to go any farther I
said if he's not going to admit it
didn't happen face to face one on one
and I challenged his courage because
yeah he had the courage to go to Iraq he
had the courage to shoot all these
people but he didn't have the courage to
tell the truth did he what a bizarre
moment that must have been sitting
across from that guy yeah and he looked
at me and said yes I did what was the
look in his face I believe and I'm not a
doctor but I've done some studying I
think he was a sociopath sociopaths can
lie and hold a straight face and they
lie to the point where they believe
their own lie how bizarre is it that
this iconic figure well and then look
how he died yeah well he had no training
in post-traumatic stress he's not
medical and yet
he's taking this marine to a gun range
who's suffering from post-traumatic
stress wouldn't common sense tell you
not to put a weapon in the hands of
someone suffering from post-traumatic
stress I think everyone if he's not
telling the manic stresses what if and
what do they tell him to man up why
would you put a weapon in somebody's
hands who's suffering from
post-traumatic stress when you have no
medical training how is quiet I'd to
treat this guy while I would assume
it'll be based on his own post-traumatic
stress but he didn't have it he didn't
have it at all now he was never treated
for it he may have had it maybe that's
why he did what he did I don't know God
what a crazy place to be but but the for
me it's like I've been accused of
something I didn't do I don't even know
the guy never I may have met him that
night briefly well Jason I died
obviously didn't get a one one millionth
of a percent of the amount of hate that
you did but just read I got read off
September 11th of this year I was in New
York doing this book tour and I got read
off in a hotel lobby over this what does
that mean read off a guy yelled and
screamed at me in front of the entire
hotel lobby Jesus Christ that's what I
live with now and I haven't been damaged
my reputation isn't damaged over
something I never did what I was going
to say is I obviously haven't
experienced one one-millionth of the
hate that you have but I read we've read
this article on the air we were trying
to figure out what happened when your
case was going on and so we read this
article that was I don't know was in the
New York Times see if you could find the
article detailing all the various lies
oh that's the new yorker magazine yorker
yorker may they did an investigation of
him but it's stunning and just reading
that the the [ __ ] amount of hate
tweets and facebook tweets and you
[ __ ] coward and you this and you that
I'm like hey I didn't write it okay I'm
just trying to figure out what the [ __ ]
is going on if someone puts something
like that in the New Yorker with
verified claims
I mean everything's verified like what
they were saying that he said and what
actually had happened was all verified
it's very very very confusing that
somehow another dis slipped through the
cracks and that this became their iconic
figure again not discounting along with
you the thousands and thousands of
patriotic Americans at risk their lives
and he is - nobody's denying he wasn't a
great sniper nobody's denying he didn't
do his job I've never denied that from
him or said that about him he may be the
best I don't know I'll still put my
money on Carlos Hathcock though the
Marine as being the best sniper
especially now but uh but uh he did his
job and he did it well but why did he
have to take an old veteran that would
be like me taking a world war two guy
and throwing him under the bus
why the [ __ ] would he choose you because
I had Fame he I think he got jealous
that night we're at the bar because
everyone crowded around and wanted their
picture with me Wow I don't know he'll
never be around to answer it I'd love to
know why he picked out me I think cuz
I'm probably the most famous maybe or I
developed to be the most famous see
leather dick Marcinko the Rogue Warrior
Green Oaks yeah read his books well he's
a friend of mine Richard Marcinko when I
sat down and you're talking to this guy
how much time were you actually in the
room with him Oh couple of minutes was
all the minute the minute he looked me
in the eye and said I sure did hit you I
turned to the judge said we got nothing
more to talk about you didn't want I was
neither offered him I said if you will
walk out to be with the press and admit
you fabricated this story I will forgive
you in front of the press and we will go
on with our lives he would not do it he
did not have the courage to stand up and
tell the truth
it takes a lot of courage to admit you
lied about something that massive I mean
this isn't lying about speeding right
this is this is a massive task what
about ruining my life ruining my
reputation ruining my wife's life
Rui I lost my conspiracy theories show
because of it really I can't get hired
right now I can't get a job my last job
was on the internet that or a TV because
the owners Carlos Slim from Mexico from
that you know who I'm hired you know who
I work for now the Russians Russian TV
artis the only people that will hire me
because 34 media conglomerates entered
this case to overturn me you think
they're gonna hire me now explain that
why do you think they did that do you
think they did that because if they
overturn your case if they can somehow
or another because they don't want is
ready fact-check but is that it or is
that discrediting you in public that was
a gigantic hit movie but if they dis if
they can discredit you it makes that
movie still valuable not only that it
stops me from running for president
don't and if they can discredit me
[Music]
you